[Musique]
bonsoir pour l'asl ailleurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
quelles conséquences aurait pu avoir une
commission d' enquête sur la sphère des
sous marins sur le gouvernement d'union
mais je souhaite mais ce n'est que ce
problème en dure depuis deux voire trois
ans et la police à enquêter sur le rôle
du premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou dans cette affaire des
sous-marins et ont découvert qu'il
n'était pas personnellement impliqué le
ministre de la défense benny ganz a
décidé de mettre en place une commission
d'enquêté qui fonctionnera d'après lui
sous les auspices du ministère de la
défense et on est en droit de se
demander pourquoi sachant qu'il ya six
mois il a rejoint un gouvernement de
coalition avec les tania ou à l'époque
benny ganz avait dit qu'il n'est pas
besoin enquête apparemment elle a changé
d'avis pourquoi et beaucoup de personnes
disent qu'il pourrait s'agir d'avancer
ses pions sur l'échiquier politique car
il a un désavantage dans les sondages
politiques
lui même dit qu'il a été forcé de
prendre cette décision après la
rencontre de plusieurs du membre du
gouvernement israélien
quant à l'effet sur le gouvernement il
est certain qu'il sera négatif cela va
renforcer les tensions et pourrait
mettre en danger voire même détruire ce
gouvernement de coalition
alors cette affaire des sous marins on
s'y intéresse un peu tout de même des
questions subsistent quant à la décision
d'acheter les navires à la firme
allemande au lieu de lancer un appel
d'offres à d'autres sociétés c'est bien
de cela qu'il s'agit
tout à fait c'est le coeur du sujet il y
à des questions sur la raison de cet
achat à hauteur de milliards de dollars
cet achat est de bâtiments aux prêts est
une entreprise allemande de 100 marchés
publics sans effectivement appel
d'offres à d'autres entreprises on pense
qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une affaire de
fraude à hauteur de milliards de dollars
benyamin nétanyahou n'est pas mise en
cause personnellement mais plusieurs de
ses proches dont des membres de sa
famille ont été impliqués l'ancien
ministre de la défense a dit que
benyamin nétanyahou devrait être soumis
à une enquête l'armée pose également des
questions concernant ces bâtiments
était-il vraiment nécessaire de les
acheter aujourd'hui clairement à qui
profite le plus ce report de commissions
oui nous avons un gouvernement de
coalition en place en israël et ce
gouvernement est en difficulté depuis le
tout début
et la raison pour quels bénéfices l'a
rejoint c'était le coronavirus un
problème qui devait être gérée mais on
lui a également promis que dans deux ans
dans 18 mois il allait lui-même devenir
premier ministre
donc à l'origine il était à son avantage
de ne pas parler de cette affaire des
sous marins mais le public israélien et
les ministres israéliens étudie la
question depuis un certain temps donc
qui en bénéficiera le plus
et bien si benyamin nétanyahou est
coupable alors que jusqu'à présent on
disait qu'il était innocent si on se
rend compte qu'il était impliqué alors
l'avantagent sera pour benny ganz cela
l'aidera dans les sondages cela
renforcera sa position niveau politique
mais quelles sont les conséquences pour
le gouvernement
le gouvernement est déjà très instable
en israël donc s'il enquête continue et
s'il enquête a un impact négatif sur
benyamin netanyahou alors le
gouvernement d'unité pourrait
s'effondrer et nous avons déjà eu trois
élections en à peine un an et ses trois
élections n'ont pas permis de former un
gouvernement viable donc ce n'est pas
une très bonne nouvelle pour le public
et les politiques israéliennes donc la
commission a reporté ce qu'on peut
s'attendre permet à ce que cette affaire
ressurgissent
effectivement la sphère pourrait
ressurgir pour le moment le procureur
général ça ferraille man the pitt doit
prendre une décision il doit décider de
ce qui va arriver
vera et même de blitta demandé à benny
ganz de reporter cette enquête
disons qu'il veut réexaminer la
procédure pénale si il décide on peut
relancer l' enquête
alors il y aura une réouverture de
l'enquêté mais s'il dit l'affairé close
alors il n'y aura plus dans kate
donc c'est bien avira et mal de public
le procureur général qui aura le fin mot
de l'affairé on attend donc de savoir ce
qu'ils décident concernant cette enquête
est le suspense reste entier donc merci
paul à slayer journalistes pour rt
internationale d'avoir été avec nous à
voir donc parler de cette affaire et
cette commission reporter merci à vous